at least two people have died in a fire
at an overcrowded Greek migrant camp the
dead are reported to be a woman and a
child that blaze struck the Moria camp
on the island of Lesbos it was later put
out but residents of the camp angry at
what they say was a slow response
clashed with police
now conditions at the camp are at a
breaking point after a sharp spike in
migrant arrivals from turkey misery upon
misery on the Greek island of Lesbos
migrants scrambled to escape a cloud of
tear gas fired by police as a tragic
chain of events unfolded at the Moria
camp a fire broke out inside the camp
quickly spreading through containers
used to house residents there are
conflicting reports about what happened
next an NGO working in the camp says a
group of migrants rushed to extinguish
the blaze and police used tear gas to
chase them away
police say they fired tear gas to
disperse rioters angered by the time it
took to preside the deadly fire
what's undisputed is that a group of
migrants attacked firefighters who
arrived on the scene a video posted on
Facebook shows the damage additional
police officers were flown in from
Athens to help restore calm conditions
at Moria have always been difficult but
in recent months they've gotten worse
migrant arrivals to Greece from Turkey
have surged reaching their highest level
since 2016 when the European Union
signed a deal with Ankara to stem the
flow about 12,000 people are currently
housed in the camp though it's only
designed for a quarter that number the
deadly fire and rioting will increase
pressure on the Greek government to ease
the situation with the harsh winter
months approaching fast
let's go straight to Athens now we're
joined by correspondent aunty Kurosawa
good morning to you auntie do we know
anything more about what might have
caused this fire at the Marea camp well
there are conflicting reports as to what
in fact caused this blaze there by one
account it was caused in fact by this
woman who was was killed in this place
because she started cooking in her
container and that quickly spread by
other accounts there were two separate
fires one fire that was set outside the
camp and then within 20 minutes another
fire set within the camp which kind of
shows an orchestrated and premeditated
kind of attempt either way the chaos
that kind of ensued and what happened
simply underscores the abysmal situation
in what is being called Europe's most
embarrassing refugee camp 13,000 people
crammed in a camp build to hold 3,000
yea abysmal is the right word with the
images were getting show just how over
crowded this campus can you tell
something about about the riots as a
result of this fire well the the riots
affectionately what happened would
ensued was that once these these fires
took took place many of the refugees who
were in there and who have been
extremely frustrated by very long stays
simply rioted because of the asylum
process that is taking so long that
however as far as rescue attempts had
had a very negative impact because the
fire fighters could not move in and and
eventually the police riot police had to
move in and fire some tear gas to
disperse these militant migrants and to
bring about some calm and to get this
rescue operation going eventually the
fire was doused out by water planes and
there is some degree of calmness
at this camp but there are great fears
among the locals that it's just a matter
of time before new riots will be
triggered anti-corrosive earth air force
in Athens